Hey, David, at this point in time, what can change
the presidential race? So I'm gonna answer this
question without weighing in on whether the race
is over it, because it doesn't. We've talked about
the poll. The national polls look very good for
Biden. But Biden is not doing quite as well in
Wisconsin, Michigan and Pennsylvania compared to
where Hillary was at this point four years ago.
Whatever each of us believes to be the situation
right now, the question is what could dramatically
change it? I think that at this point in time, we
really are looking only at big, big issues like a
health issue for one of the candidates. If one of
the candidates were to be truly very ill, where it
would be unclear that they would make it to the
inauguration. I do think that that would change
how people decide to vote a major credible crime
allegation against one of the candidates. I don't
mean Trump at rallies saying Biden and Obama spied
on me and they should be indicted. That's not what
I mean by a major credible. Trump hasn't even
said what crime was committed, supposedly when he
says that. But like a real story that takes over
about, wow, Trump or Biden accused of X, Y or Z.
Remember many of the sexual assault
allegations against Biden, sorry against
Trump were certainly crimes at the time. And you
can talk about statute of limitations or whatever.
Didn't make a difference in 2016. I don't believe
the third debate, if it happens, will change
anything again, unless there's a major failure
by someone, a medical event during the debate.
Some you know, if Trump starts yelling the N-word
during the debate, I do think it would have an
impact. I know his his core base might not care,
but there are people who are just slightly over
on the Trump side who know if Trump starts calling
black people the N-word, for example, or a Jews,
the K word or something. I think that that that
would have an impact. Some people have written
to me and said, David, don't you think Joe Biden
being unwilling to say whether or not he will pack
the court, don't you think that that's hurting
him? I don't. And I'll tell you why. On balance,
you might say if a candidate clearly isn't
answering a question directly, it hurts them.
And so there may be some way in which some
people aren't pleased that Joe Biden is not
willing to say whether he will or won't pack the
court. There's a different side to the strategy,
which is by not saying it. He maintains it as
a threat to Republicans, which may be useful.
Whereas if Biden says, I won't do it, they're off
the hook. And if Biden says I will do it, then
they just campaign against Biden because Biden
says he will pack the court. Now, my belief is
Biden will not pack the court that you can go back
and see Biden's previous statements about packing
the court. I don't think Biden has any intention
of packing the court, much to the dismay of many
people on the left. But I it's not so clear to
me that Biden not answering that question is
really doing damage. I certainly don't think it's
going to change the outcome of the election. So
this close to the election, particularly
with so many people having already voted.
It's very difficult to change what the outcome
is going to be. Now, the outcome ultimately may
not reflect the will of the people because of foul
play, because of foul play with absentee ballots,
because of the use of lawyers and courts to try to
stop the counting of said ballots. So on. And so
but that's that's something that is not about
events on the campaign trail. And if you take
Allan Lichtman, his approach to predicting
elections, which is a qualitative approach, it's
less about this happened in a debate. It's more
circumstantial what's going on in the country.
He would argue that the cake is already baked.
He happens to think Biden will win. He may be
right. He may be wrong. Biden. Biden may win
the popular vote and yet not win electorally,
in which case. Did Allan Lichtman get it right or
not? We could debate that. But the idea would be
this late in the game. Only a.
Candidate becoming incapacitated
would change the situation because with a
qualitative analysis, the circumstances in
the country over the last four years are what they
are. And that is what will determine the outcome.
We will have to wait and see and we
won't have to wait that much longer.